this is Sylvester a three-year-old  sulawesi Turek tick hornbill endemic to  Sulawesi Indonesia it's once plentiful  population is now rapidly declining  Sylvester is on the smaller side at  about a foot and a half hornbills in  general are characterized by their long  curved bills this specific species makes  its home in the tropical lowlands swamps  and forests of Sulawesi and nearby  islands where it feeds mainly on fruit  with the occasional small animal but  destruction of these areas has caused a  massive drop in population that along  with being hunted for food and the pet  trade has left this once common bird  harder to spot this is the Sulawesi to  richtek horn bell